[Musik]
härte gegen die opposition trotz verbots
demonstrieren zehntausende in russland
gegen die verhaftung des kreml kritikers
navalny ärger um astrazeneca der
pharmakonzern kann vorerst offenbar nur
einen teil der bestellten eu impfdosen
liefern höchste rate an neuinfektionen
weltweit in portugal müssen cupid
patienten vor den krankenhäusern waren
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers sonnabend in allen an
diesem samstagabend hier ist ihr
nachrichtenüberblick heute und sieben
mit sport natürlich und natürlich mit
kristin otto mega sport tag heute guten
abend zehntausende menschen
demonstrierten heute in russland für die
freilassung des kreml-kritikers alexej
nawalny allein in moskau waren es nach
schätzungen von reportern vor ort
mindestens 40.000 auf einer der größten
unerlaubten demonstrationen seit jahren
die behörden drohen mit hohen strafen
navalny war am sonntag direkt bei seiner
rückkehr nach moskau festgenommen worden
und trotz möglicher lange haftstrafe
trotz des giftanschlags im august
navalny und sein team wollen
weitermachen
der kreml sei korrupt sagen sie sie
haben ein video veröffentlicht das
zeigen soll dass präsident putin an der
schwarzmeerküste einen großen palast
besitze finanziert aus undurchsichtigen
quellen
der kreml wies das zurück aus moskau
berichtet axel sturm ein kommando genügt
und innerhalb von sekunden schlagen sie
zu
spezialeinheiten wie hier in
jekaterinburg dick gepanzert prügeln
zerren reißen an menschen die gegen den
willen des russischen staates auf der
straße sind rund 2100 festnahmen
landesweit zur stunde
es hat sich gar nicht die frage gestellt
ob wir kommen oder nicht wir mussten her
kommen
wir müssen zeigen dass das volk für
seine rechte kämpfen kann
ich bin für die freiheit hier und für
die zukunft dieser 14-jährige junge geht
im netz viral auch er wird festgenommen
weil er interviews gegeben hat demos
heute von chabarowsk bis sankt
petersburg zehntausende sind dem ruf von
kremlkritiker alexej nawalny gefolgt der
am sonntag nach seiner rückkehr aus
deutschland inhaftiert worden war wie
seine frau heute
sie meldet sich auf instagram direkt aus
dem gefangenen transporter
inzwischen ist sie wieder frei
auch in moskau auf dem puschkin-platz
protestieren sie gegen die behandlung
der navis zu hören sind aber auch klare
nachrichten an den staatschef putin ist
ein dieb rufen sie sie alle sind
unzufrieden und nicht nur navis rückkehr
ist der impuls der sie auf die straße
treibt auch sein neues video über putin
und den palast am schwarzen meer
veröffentlicht kurz nach seiner rückkehr
navalny beschuldigt den staatschef darin
einen pompösen palast zu besitzen
finanziert aus dubiosen geldquellen
der kreml hat das zurückgewiesen 70
millionen menschen haben den netz schon
gesehen die opposition wünscht sich dass
auch am kommenden wochenende wieder
tausende ihrem ärger luft machen beginn
live nach moskau zu christian semmeln
der die demonstrationen heute in moskau
beobachtet hat christian was ist dein
eindruck
ja ich stehe ja am puschkinplatz der
putzigen platz der war heute das zentrum
der proteste und was wir heute gesehen
haben war wirklich massiver protest und
die menschen die sind nicht nur für
alexej nawalny auf die straße gegangen
die haben ihre große unzufriedenheit
hier zum ausdruck gebracht gegen die
korruption im land gegen die
staatsführung und auch gegen die eigene
eingeschränkte freiheit was ich hier
heute bemerkenswert fanden war die große
solidarität zum beispiel der autofahrer
die hier vorbeigefahren sind und ein
stundenlanges hupkonzert abgegeben haben
um die menschen am straßenrand zu
unterstützen
die haben zurückgefunden und bilder wie
diese die haben wir letztes jahr schon
zum beispiel bei den protesten in
belarus gesehen wie viel sorge postämter
kreml jetzt haben vor dieser
oppositionsbewegung auch was die
kommenden wochen angeht also was die
kommenden wochen angeht wenn man mit den
menschen hier spricht die russinnen und
russen mit denen wir heute hier
gesprochen haben gesagt wir sind auch
bereit weiter auf die straße zu gehen
denn unsere forderungen sollen natürlich
auch erfüllt werden und auch die
unterstützer von alexei navalny haben
angekündigt dass es nächste woche
bereits neue proteste geben soll
die große frage ist wie der kreml darauf
reagiert wir können davon ausgehen dass
die reaktionen massiv sein wird denn
solche massenansammlungen die wird man
hier nicht dulden wollen und wir kennen
das von anderen
massendemonstrationen zum beispiel in
moskau und hier 2009/10 da haben wir das
gesehen wie die auch brutal
niedergeschlagen werden was jetzt
diesmal in diesem jahr vielleicht den
entscheidenden unterschied macht das die
proteste im ganzen land stattgefunden
haben
christian selben live aus moskau
herzlichen dank für diese analyse und
damit heute abend in der sendung nach
deutschland und zur lage im kampf gegen
korona die zahl der neuen infektionen
bei uns geht weiter zurück
das robert koch institut meldet 16.000
417 fälle innerhalb von 24 stunden das
sind 2261 weniger als letzten samstag
weiter hoch bleibt die zahl der
todesfälle 879 menschen starben in
verbindung mit cupid 19 und
problematisch ist auch weiter die lage
für die besonders verwundbaren die die
eigentlich auch besonders zu schützen
sein müssten
hagen nicolas berichtet aus einem
altenheim in sachsen-anhalt
schichtwechsel im pflegeheim krüger in
dedeleben im vorharz ffp zwei maske und
tägliche antigen tests sind pflicht für
alle angestellten und für gäste die
strikten regeln sollen die 40 bewohner
innen und 30 mitarbeiter in den schützen
und sie erlauben etwas geselligkeit
zumindest in kleiner runde
die anti gen tests für alle hat das heim
im dezember die ffb zwei masken pflicht
bereits im sommer eingeführt beides
früher als die verordnung der politik
ist forderten die aktuellen corona
schutzregeln hält man dem pflegeheim für
teilweise zu lückenhaft
notfallmedizinischen roth vom
rettungsdienst notarzt wo einfach wir
uns darauf verlassen müssen dass die
sich dieser tests durchführen
das ist teilweise wir wissen aber nicht
der fall
dass der chor ohne schutz in
pflegeheimen noch immer nicht
ausreichend sei auch aus sicht von
expertinnen ein problem
es ist vielleicht in der breite noch
nicht ausreichend angekommen welche
schutzmaßnahmen wirklich wie konkret
umzusetzen sind ich denke nicht jedes
pflegeheim ist bis jetzt gut aufgestellt
tatsächlich ganz regelmäßig zum beispiel
diese einzigen schnelltest zu machen
und eben das hygiene konzept wirklich
für jede situation auch schon bereit zu
haben im pflegeheim dedeleben sollen
demnächst alle bewohner innen und
angestellten die es möchten die zweite
kurve 19 impfung erhalten dann hoffen
sie noch besser gegen einen krone
ausbruch gewappnet zu sein
in berlin deswegen des corona virus ein
gesamtes krankenhaus unter quarantäne
gestellt worden
bei einem routine screening war bei
bislang 20 angestellten und patienten
die ansteckende variante aus
großbritannien entdeckt worden
in dem klinikum werden jetzt vorerst
keine patienten mehr aufgenommen auch
keine notfälle mehr besucher dürfen bis
auf wenige ausnahmen nicht mehr ins
gebäude
das personal musste sich in so genannte
pendelt quarantäne begeben das heißt die
mitarbeiter dürfen nur noch nach hause
und in die klinik fahren knapp 1,5
millionen menschen haben in deutschland
ihre erste impfung bekommen alle
wünschen sich natürlich mehr tempo doch
das hängt wesentlich davon ab wie viel
impfstoff verfügbar ist auf drei
hersteller setzt deutschland im moment
schauen wir uns das mal an biontech
pfizer liefert am meisten reduziert aber
vorübergehend weil ein werk umgebaut
wird moderner die lieferungen laufen
erst an bis jetzt wurden nur knapp
20.000 menschen
diesem impfstoff geimpft und astrazeneca
der impfstoff könnte nächste woche
zugelassen werden jetzt gibt es aber
meldungen dass auch dieser konzern sehr
viel weniger liefern könnte als
eigentlich geplant
die eu koordiniert den einkauf für
europa günter krüger ist für uns in
brüssel
wieso wird denn die eu immer wieder böse
überrascht von den firmen was die
tatsächlich möglichen lieferungen angeht
ja auf jeden fall mag die eu kommission
diese überraschungen nicht denn jede
überraschung frist vertrauen auf
vertrauen der eu kommission in die
hersteller aber natürlich auch vertrauen
der bürger in diese einkaufsgemeinschaft
der 27 die ja immer damit argumentiert
hat wir haben die produktionskapazitäten
genau geprüft und eben erst dann unsere
verträge abgeschlossen
deshalb habe es so lange gedauert diese
argumentation die bekommt dadurch
natürlich einen knacks man gibt sich
hier jetzt nun tief und zufrieden aus
zwei gründen zum einen weil man die
kommunikation von astrazeneca nicht
versteht die möchten ja eigentlich kein
geld gewinn machen sondern nur einen
image-gewinn wie kann man dann so
kommunizieren und auf der anderen seite
fragt man sich wie kann die
produktionskette so anfällig sein weil
so vielen werken in europa also der
erwartet die kommission antworten vom
hersteller und zwar bis montag aber klar
ist auch egal wie diese antworten
ausfallen die kommission bleibt bei
ihrer überzeugung es war richtig
gemeinsam zu bestellen andernfalls hätte
man zwar mehr geld ausgegeben aber nicht
mehr impfstoff bekommen viele fragen
viele antworten die noch ausstehen und
nach vielen dank nach brüssel
wir bleiben noch moment beim thema
portugal war bisher vergleichsweise gut
durch die pandemie gekommen
doch jetzt gehen die zahlen in die höhe
und zwar drastisch laut johns hopkins
universität hat portugal aktuell den
höchsten sieben tages inzidenz wird auf
der ganzen welt nämlich 790 seit mitte
der woche werden täglich etwa 14.000
neue infektionen gemeldet und das bei
nur etwa zehn millionen einwohnern für
diesen anstieg ist laut regierung vor
allem die britische virus mutation
verantwortlich und entsprechend
dramatisch die situation in den
krankenhäusern wie thomas walde
sonst findet ihr kampfsport stadt bald
kämpfen patienten ums überleben
notbehelf in lissabon portugals
krankenhäuser arbeiten am limit und
darüber hinaus das personal will helfen
und kann es doch immer weniger
wir sehen patienten in den krankenwagen
die in die notaufnahme müssen die
medizinisch versorgt werden müssen und
wissen dabei doch dass wir am ende nicht
genügend platz im krankenhaus für sie
haben viele kollegen können nicht mehr
und haben nervenzusammenbrüche und es
wird mit jedem tag schlimmer
lange kam portugal recht gut durch die
krise durch eine mutation lässt die
zahlen seit kurzem sprunghaft ansteigen
es gibt sehr viele positive tests und
der anteil der britischen variante liegt
bereits bei 13 prozent
inzwischen sollen es sogar 20 prozent
seien portugal reagiert flüge von und
nach großbritannien werden eingestellt
der nationale lockdown verschärft wegen
der neuen variante und der schnellen
ausbreitung müssen wir aus vorsicht alle
schulischen aktivitäten für die nächsten
zwei wochen einstellen
trotz der pandemie gehen die
vorbereitungen für die morgige
präsidentschaftswahl weiter
es ist wichtig den portugiesen zu zeigen
dass es die wahlen gibt und die
demokratie nicht ausgesetzt ist
erwartet wird dass der bisherige
präsident wiedergewählt wird offen ist
wie viele portugiesen aus angst vor dem
virus nicht zur wahl gehen
weitere nachrichten zur lage im in und
ausland finden sie in der zdf- heute-
app der korona blog hält sie mit allem
was wichtig ist auf dem laufenden
und jetzt hier bei uns weitere wichtige
nachrichten von diesem samstag in den
usa geht das zweite
amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen ex
präsident donald trump weiter der
prozess soll jetzt in der zweiten
februar woche beginnen
demokraten und republikaner im us-senat
einigten sich auf diesen termin
die anklageschrift des
repräsentantenhauses soll noch heute
abend im senat verlesen werden
darin wird trump anstiftung zum aufruhr
vorgeworfen
zurück zu uns 2021 ist ein superwahljahr
in deutschland mit der bundestagswahl
und mit insgesamt sechs landtagswahlen
mit als erste sind am 14 märz die baden
württembergerin und baden württemberger
dran
umfragen sehen die grünen von
ministerpräsident winfried kretschmann
vorne knapp vor der cdu
die war die letzten jahre juniorpartner
in der koalition und will jetzt wieder
stärkste kraft werden die fahrschüler
sie will den grünen ministerpräsidenten
stürzen
cdu-spitzenkandidatin susanne eisenmann
wie schwer es ist corona und wahlkampf
zu trennen
davon zeugt nicht nur die kulisse des
parteitags als kultusministerin muss
eisenmann die gemeinsame corona politik
rechtfertigen sich aber gleichzeitig vom
ministerpräsidenten abgrenzen
das ist ein schlüssel mit gestalten zu
tun mit zukunft annehmen und nicht mit
philosophieren da unterscheiden wir uns
glaube ich einfach grundlegend die cdu
mit der energischen eisenmann liegt in
den meisten umfragen nur knapp hinter
den grünen mit dem bedächtigen
ministerpräsidenten allerdings sind
kretschmanns beliebtheitswerte deutlich
größer mit dem wahlkämpfen hat er es
weniger eilig versucht etwa mit podcast
die menschen zu erreichen
der pandemie nicht die stimmung sind da
sehr sehr volatil und es kann die eine
oder andere richtung kippen da muss man
sich nicht einbilden dass wir da
irgendwo auf der sicheren seite sein
kann
die spd sucht nähe auf abstand sie liegt
in umfragen bei etwa 10% und hat vor
allem ein ziel mit den grünen regieren
wir wollen dass die nächsten jahre nicht
wie der verlorene jahre in baden
württemberg sind die letzten viereinhalb
fünf jahre mit grün schwarz waren
politisch verlorene jahre
wir wollen als spd konkret mitgestalten
umfragen zufolge wäre so ein bündnis
aber nur mit der fdp möglich die würde
lieber mit cdu und spd koalieren aber
hauptsache regieren die deutschland
koalition liegt uns inhaltlich leer aber
wir sind aufgeschlossen machen nach
inhalten einen wahlkampf nicht nach
farbenlehre die afg hat noch keinen
spitzenkandidaten nominiert in umfragen
liegt sie etwa bei 11 prozent
die wichtigsten themen jetzt im
wahlkampf ist natürlich die situation
die lockdown situation die locker und
politik der bundesregierung der
landesregierungen und sicherlich
natürlich auch die wirtschaftlichen
implikationen nichts ist wie es sonst
war bei diesem wahlkampf die größte
herausforderung die wähler irgendwie
erreichen und richtig einschätzen
die renten werden in diesem jahr
voraussichtlich kaum steigen
sozialminister hubertus heil erwartet
dass es im westen gar keine erhöhungen
geben wird und im osten nur eine sehr
geringe das sagte er der rheinischen
post hintergrund die rentenentwicklung
folgt der lohnentwicklung des vorjahres
und die blieb im corona jahr 2020 gleich
starker schneefall wie kein autofahrer
ihnen sich würden stadt im osten
deutschlands für chaotische
verkehrsverhältnisse gesorgt am morgen
ging es auf der a 72 bei zwickau gar
nicht mehr vorwärts hunderte lkw blieben
im schnee stecken manchmal gelang es
auch dem thw nicht sie frei zu schleppen
die autobahn war über stunden blockiert
und es bleibt dort auch erstmal
winterlich und soll weiter schneien
gummistiefel wetter dagegen an der mosel
dort steigen die pegelstände uferstraßen
spielplätze stehen bereits unter wasser
vielmehr wetter gleich erst sehr viel
sport und gleich mal rein wintersport
eine woche vor den rodel
weltmeisterschaften hat felix loch
vorzeitig den gesamtweltcup gewonnen
im eiskanal von innsbruck setzt der
routinier seine eindrucksvolle und
bisher einmalige siegesserie in diesem
winter folgt rekord jubel acht
weltcup-rennen acht siege von einem
einzigen rodler
das hat es noch nie gegeben zwei
wettbewerbe vor schluss ist felix loch
vorzeitig zum siebten mal
gesamtweltcupsieger mit bahnrekord hat
loch in innsbruck igls die bislang beste
weltcup saison seines lebens gefeiert
und geht als ungeschlagener favorit in
die heim-wm in der kommenden woche in
königssee seiner hausbahn in lahti
finnland hat das laufstarke norwegische
pop duo jan magnus rieber und yang
chrobok den team-sprint gewonnen und an
den zweiten deutschen sieg verhinderte
unveränderter formation verpassten damit
die staffel olympiasieger vinzenz geiger
und fabian rießle wiederum einen
deutschen erfolg hinter japan platzieren
sich eric frenzel und terence weber auf
dem vierten rang
ebenfalls in lacht die hat das deutsche
skisprung team eine woche nach dem
sturzflug in zakopane wieder das podest
erreicht mit der bestweite von 129
metern ist es am ende karl geiger der
das deutsche team auf platz drei fliegen
lässt fast schief gegangen wäre der
letzte sprung von norwegens gerne ruht
der sich aber noch fängt um mit seinem
team vor polen gewinnt nervenflattern
bei den bayern verfolgern zum
rückrundenstart in der
fußball-bundesliga leipzig verliert in
mainz 23 da gibt es nachher redebedarf
im aktuellen sportstudio leverkusen
unterliegt wolfsburg 0 zu 1 augsburg
bremst mit 221 union berlin aus souverän
frankfurt 5 zu 1 in bielefeld freiburg 2
2 1 gegen stuttgart alles zum abendspiel
härter bremen auch im sportstudio
gestern gladbach dortmund 4 2 morgen
empfängt schlusslicht schalke
tabellenführer bayern münchen und
mannheim köln die bayern können als
spitzenreiter ihren vorsprung auf sieben
punkte ausbauen an leipzig und
leverkusen rücken wolfsburg und gladbach
dortmund runter auf 7
am tabellenende könnte sich köln noch
höher schieben mainz und schalke bleiben
auf den abstiegsplätzen und noch zur
handball wm in ägypten bei der die
deutsche mannschaft arg unter
erfolgsdruck steht und gleichzeitig auf
zwei niederlagen der ungarn angewiesen
ist lena kesting wir spielen gerade
gegen polen wie sieht's aus
es sieht nicht gut aus für die deutsche
mannschaft den rund fünf minuten vor
apfel fühlen die ungarn hier mit sechs
toren das bedeutet dass die polen eben
nicht die schützenhilfe leisten könnte
die das dhb team aber unbedingt braucht
um eine chance aufs wm viertelfinale zu
wahren trotzdem selbst wenn das so
bleibt will die deutsche mannschaft hier
gegen brasilien heute abend unbedingt
gewinnen
zum einen um nochmal tollen handball zu
präsentieren und zum anderen um auf
erfahrungen zusammen mit blick auf die
olympia quali gegner brasilien ist vor
der partie schwer einzuschätzen
die haben toll gespielt gegen spanien
haben ein unentschieden herausgeholt
aber auf der anderen seite auch nur
unentschieden gegen die mannschaft aus
tunesien gespielt unterm strich sind die
deutschen seit favorit einzuschätzen und
brasilien ist sehr wohl leichteste
gegner gegen den der thw in dieser runde
gewinnen will den er vielen dank nach
ägypten und viertel nach acht geht es
dann mit der handball übertragung los
hier im zdf kristin vielen dank an dich
sehr gern wie versprochen das wetter
nach dem schnee ist vor dem schnee
wo aber morgen auch mal die sonne
scheint erklärt uns gleich katja
horneffer die kollegin marietta slomka
gegen 21 uhr 10 so ungefähr in der
handball pause mit dem heute journal
wir vom team heute 19 sind auch morgen
für sie da und zwar sehr gerne
bis dann aber erst in allen einen
angenehm alt
[Musik]
meine damen und herren sechs benannte
tiefs über europa sehen wir auch nicht
alle tage das ist ein richtiges
tiefdruck ballett bestehend aus koran
hakimi reck josef kaspar und lars dusty
viereck brachte regen und schnee vor
allem gegen den baden württemberg bayern
und sachsen und zieht jetzt weiter nach
nordosten für den schnee morgen ist das
tief yusuf verantwortlich wenn es so
viele tiefs gibt über mitteleuropa dann
liegen die temperaturen nachts nicht so
besonders niedrig heute nacht erwarten
uns dies temperaturen zwischen plus zwei
und minus fünf grad das sind
temperaturen in denen die schneeflocken
besonders groß werden und schnee und
schneeregen ziehen jetzt von südwesten
auf besonders kräftig schneien wird es
wohl im sauerland morgen zieht das tief
yusuf dann weiter in den nordosten
machen sie sich nach wie vor auf
gefährlich glatte straßen gefasst eine
chance auf sonne haben sie im nordwesten
aber auch westlich des rheins und in
super statt
die höchsttemperaturen liegen morgen
zwischen minus ein und plus 5 grad und
die neue woche startet nach wie vor
winterlich schnee fällt am ehesten im
süden die sonne sehen sie häufiger mal
im norden und das bei temperaturen
zwischen minus zwei und plus vier grad
schönen abend noch und ein schönes
wochenende